ce avec l'intimidation sur les chantiers
c'est pas un phénomène nouveau cet homme
a enquêté sur ce phénomène justement
isabel richer a raconté à la commission
que c'est un mal durant rayé oui jean
françois sabourin qui est cet enquêteur
a recueilli beaucoup d'informations
depuis 2009 et jusqu'à récemment donc
c'est pas des affaires classées il ya
dans toutes les régions du québec
d'ailleurs pas seulement sur la côte
nord de l'île des exemples partout mais
c'est vrai que c'est toujours les noms
les mêmes noms qui surgissent celui de
bernard gauthier à sept-îles celui de
michel bezeau qui était associé jusqu'à
récemment il est maintenant dans la
région de montréal mais il ya aussi la
rue roy en gaspésie y en avait un autre
au saguenay bref c'est partout mais là
où les problèmes les plus aigus sont
notés c'est là où les locaux syndicaux
contrôler la main d'oeuvre dans des
régions et dans des métiers
donc on est en situation de
quasi-monopole de sorte que les
employeurs ont à peu près pas de
l'attitude on leur impose de
travailleurs ont leur on exige des
conditions de travail de données ça fait
monter les coûts et puis si on leur
donne pas et dont paralyse les chantiers
alors vous voyez les employeurs celle
dont l'entente du parce qu'ils ont par
des ennuis ils veulent pas de trouble et
même les donneurs d'ouvragé cède je vous
ai sélectionné un extrait vous allez
entendre un représentant qui veut faire
travailler son son homme sont
travailleurs mais il travaille est
syndiquée csd et il veut le faire le
placer sur le chantier de la romaine et
voici ce qu'un représentants
d'hydro-québec lui répond et de la
difficulté à référé sont membres il
comprend pas pourquoi il y a de la
difficulté à référé segment donc
ce qui me rapporte c'est lors d'une
discussion avec un responsable chez
hydro québec
concernant la faune le fait qu'il peut
pas placer six sont membres le
représentant de d'hydro-québec lui
mentionne pas les propos que je rapporte
il faut que tu appelles bernard gauthier
c'est lui qui se coupe ça on a les mains
liées bon à lorient menait large bernard
gauthier est justement sur bernard
gauthier dit rambo a commenté sur sa
page facebook le témoignage d'un énorme
en peine naudières oui effectivement il
le tourner en dérision ils l'accusent de
jouer à la victime
il dit qu'il le fait sa fortune sur le
dos des travailleurs je vous rappelle
que monsieur pernaut c'est celui qui a
témoigné hier et dont le chantier a été
pris d'assaut par des fiers à bras
il dit monsieur gautier que mais c'est
que monsieur faites-nous l'entrepreneur
tout une feuille de route et il l'écrit
fini son message en disant on va voir ce
qu'on peut faire avec ça et il reçoit
beaucoup beaucoup d'appuis sur son
compte facebook de gens de la région
bien sûr qu'ils se défendent en disant
on veut on veut travailler chez nous que
les travailleurs du saguenay reste au
saguenay alors on voit qu'il ya aussi un
problème de compréhension alors on n'est
pas sorti de l'auberge patrice et non
merci je vous en prie au revoir